let's go get it kill go go
much in stop all the way first gear oh
stop
oh you got this all right let's go
[Music]
have you ever drove a stick before never
have i've always wanted to but i've
never
uh had the time that automatic get in
and go yeah listen
you're about to get an opportunity to
drive this beautiful jetta gli
one of the best drivers in the world my
guy tanner he's gonna teach you how to
let's get it bro
anytime you shift this you need to push
the clutch
so that's the first thing you'll notice
is there's an extra pedal now
this guy right there yes
so every time you move this put that in
there so we want to start off in first
gear so you go just a little bit to the
left
and then up when you let out the clutch
you start to feel that it's kind of
grabbing and moving the car
i can just add a little gas and then
let the clutch out the rest of the way
once we get moving so that's that so
right now the car wants to get into the
next gear you can hear there's yep
second gear and then again
once it's in then i just drive away
should we swap let's go you got this
so with your foot on the brake and the
clutch go ahead and put it in first
let off the brake there you go oh there
we go now we might now we're done
well this is going to be yeah
[Music]
so tell me todd what what motivates you
to be so competitive
i see that you always playing hard
you're always going hard it's really
just how i grew up
like i felt like growing up if i wanted
to make it to where i
where i'm at right now i had to be a dog
and just kill everybody
right really and the engine and the
answer exactly
that's how you do it hey accelerate
accelerate
yep and go okay not bad
how's it feeling right now bro i love it
it's a a great ride like it just feels
good
you know you just need repetition just
to get muscle memory
clutch clutch clutch there you go saved
at that time oh damn
first gear might be okay there it is
he ain't no rookie oh now he's burning
hey it's a great handle feels like i'm
you know in transition on the court
yeah you know on the road yeah back
if you like it you need more reps yeah
okay
obstacle course bro you got two laps you
got to stop at the landmarks the red
flags
complete stop you got to do it in 130.
if you complete the task
you get to take the victory lap around
the real track over there bro hey you
got this bro i believe in you
hey don't start it early now i'm not
ma'am i started late for you to get you
a little bit of time
let's go let's go baby
you got this ah let's go
get it go go go
oh my god stop all the way first gear oh
stop
okay we're scared there we go 228
furious horses good remember the clutch
there you go good all right come on man
let's go
we're out here all right you can get it
going 1 30. oh you got 10 seconds
10 9 8 7
six five four
three two one stop clutch
131 131 let's go
well i'm gonna tell you right now you
did a hell of a job bro the shift is
like a different
a different feel i think it's a lot more
fun than automatic cars
but i definitely liked it this is more
of a better experience and once you
really get the hang of it it's probably
really fun to do you know 1 30 was the
time to beat you got 131 i i think i
might have
started the time a little early
a little late but i'll give you that you
still you get to take you know the
little victory lap on the mount on the
main track
all right thank you deal thing nine and
three
nine three oh that's my guy
got that done baby let's go